what is the government's guidance to
single parents who have
good afternoon i'm joined this afternoon
by dr susan hopkins of
nhs test and trace in public health
england and sir patrick
valance chief scientific advisor on
monday i explained that we would seek to
consult with mayors and local
authorities
in areas moving into the very high alert
level
i'm grateful to all those in local
government in hot spot areas
who've been working with us over the
last week on how to control the virus
in their areas in particular i would
like to thank steve
rotheram in merseyside sadiq khan in
london
and local leaders in lancashire who've
worked constructively
with us in merseyside where the
situation is most acute we were able
to conclude talks quickly in london
we've worked with the mayor to respond
to rising
infections across the capital as well as
particular spikes
in some boroughs and in lancashire today
we have worked with both labour and
conservative leaders
to agree a package these were tough
discussions difficult decisions
no one wants to have to implement these
measures which
damage local businesses curtail
individual freedom and impose
significant strains on people's mental
health
but these decisions were necessary
because of the rate of increase not just
of infections
but also in hospitalizations and
admissions
to intensive care without action there
is no doubt
that our nhs would soon be struggling to
treat the sheer
number of people seriously ill with
kobit
non-kobe treatments and surgeries
would need to be cancelled in order to
cope
and many more people would die
so taking action is the right and
responsible thing to do
and it is backed up by significant
support for areas
on very high alert the job support
scheme
combined with universal credit means
that those on low incomes
who are affected by business closures
will receive at least
80 percent of their wages we're
providing
up to 465 million pounds to help very
high
alert level areas to implement and
enforce the restrictions in addition
to the one billion pounds of extra
funding for local authorities
across the country we will work with
local authorities to
allocate testing and introduce local
contact tracing now
we have not yet reached an agreement
with greater manchester
i completely understand the reluctance
of the mayor
and his colleagues to take manchester
into the
very high alert level it's far from a
pain-free course of action and it will
mean a difficult time
for the people of that great part of the
country
on top of the restrictions they've
already had to endure
since the summer but i must stress
the situation in greater manchester is
grave and it worsens
with each passing day cases doubled in
the last
nine days high infection rates are
creeping up
the age range age range while cases are
690
per 100 000 for 16 to 29 year olds
they've now risen
to 224 per 100 000
for the over 60s the number of covered
inpatients
in manchester's icu beds is already
over 40 of the number at the height of
the first wave
that number will inevitably rise further
given that hospitalization
occurs two to three weeks after
infection
on present trends in just over two weeks
there will be more
covered patients in intensive care
than at the peak of the first wave
so i urge the mayor to reconsider
and engage constructively i cannot
stress enough
time is of the essence each day that
passes before action
is taken means more people will go to
hospital
more people will end up in intensive
care and
tragically more people will die of
course
if agreement cannot be reached i will
need
to intervene in order to protect
manchester's hospitals and save the
lives of manchester's
residents but our efforts
will be so much more effective if we
work
together some have argued that we should
introduce
a national lockdown instead of targeted
local action and i disagree closing
businesses in cornwall
where transmission is low will not cut
transmission
in manchester so while i can't rule
anything out
if at all possible i want to avoid
another
national lockdown with the damaging
health economic
and social effects it would have
alongside our local strategy we've been
working
throughout to find other ways to
suppress
this virus we're backing our brilliant
scientists leading the global effort to
find a safe
and effective vaccine we've also secured
early access
to over 350 million vaccine doses
through a portfolio
of promising new vaccines to ensure that
we're in the best place
and we're taking every possible step to
ensure we can move as quickly as
possible
to deploy a vaccine if and when
one is found to work and we've created
a huge diagnostics industry
from scratch scaling up the ability to
test
from 2000 in february to more than 300
000
today i also want
to update on our future approach to
testing we're now testing more people
than any other country
in europe but we always want to go
further
one of the most dangerous aspects of
this disease
is that people without any symptoms
can infect many others without realizing
it
if we can catch more asymptomatic
people before they unknowingly pass on
the disease
to the vulnerable we can help to stop
the viruses vicious spread so far
it's been difficult to do this but that
is changing
scientists and companies in britain and
around the world have been developing
new tests which are faster simpler
and cheaper they've been working hard to
discover
and evaluate new testing technologies
though there is work to do it's becoming
clear over the past
few weeks that some of these new tests
are highly effective and can help us
save lives and jobs over the winter
we've already bought millions of these
tests
some of which are very simple meaning
you simply need
to wipe the swab inside your mouth
and can give a result as quickly as in
15 minutes
some of these fast tests work with
saliva
and we're already using these in
hospitals
we've started building the
infrastructure for domestic
manufacture of these tests ensuring that
britain has the ability to produce
millions
of fast tests here over the next few
weeks
we will start distributing and trialing
these tests
across the country this will enable us
to do quick turnaround tests on
nhs and care home staff much more
frequently by testing more frequently
and quickly
than ever before we can hope we can hope
we can help
prevent the spread of the virus
spreading
through care homes and we will be able
to test students
in universities without breaks as well
as
children in schools helping us to keep
education
open safely through the winter
and we will make tests available to
local directors of public health
to help control localized outbreaks
handing more control from london to all
parts of our country
so that those on the ground can use the
tools we give them
as they think best and i've instructed
my team
to ensure that liverpool city region
lancashire
and any other areas which enter into the
very high alert level
are immediately prioritized for those
tests
this will make a big difference in how
we protect
people from this disease but it's vital
that we all take a cautious approach to
this
new technology first it will take time
to develop this plan no country in the
world is regularly testing
millions of people so we need to take
the time to establish
how to do this effectively and safely
and to build the logistics and
distribution operation necessary
for a large-scale operation across the
country
second we won't be able to use
testing to get business back to normal
quickly in time we want to use tests to
open
keep open more parts of the economy that
have sadly been closed
but it is crucial that we use that we
make sure
that such systems work safely and i i
must level with you
that it will take time to get this right
before many organizations can buy and
operate
these tests themselves
third this will need a huge effort
across the country and we will need
hospitals care homes schools
universities
and other organizations to work with us
as we develop this plan
but the most important thing is that
people
isolate if they test positive
if you test positive with one of these
fast new tests then you must
stay at home if everyone follows the
rule and sale
self-isolates if you have symptoms get a
positive test
or come into contact with someone who
has the virus
we will suppress the disease
and we must all remember that this virus
thrives on human contact
so we must do everything in our power to
limit its spread
always think hands face space
ventilate your buildings wear a face
covering in enclosed spaces
keep your distance from others and make
sure
as i say that you improve ventilation
when spending time indoors
if we all do these simple things we'll
protect each other
from the virus and we will defeat it
together
i'll hand over to patrick valance who'll
run through the latest
data and we'll then go to your questions
uh
sir patrick thanks very much prime
minister can i have the first slide
please
i want to talk through just three
numbers which is the
prevalence i the number of people who've
got the infection in the uk
the incidence that is the number of new
infections every day
and the r value which tells us how much
this is
um spreading between people so this is
the
uh data that comes from the office of a
national statistics survey which is the
most reliable way to get
a handle on what's happening across the
country and it's an estimate of the
number of people who have
covered at any one time and what you can
see is that from may
the numbers went down and they got down
to quite low levels
over july and august but then began to
creep up during august
and now have taken a big increase again
in the last couple of weeks
and the latest data from the ons
estimate that 336 000
people have covid across the uk
in the last two week period so that's
the sort of numbers we're talking about
in terms of the prevalence the number of
people with the infection at the moment
next slide please the incidence is the
number of new infections per day
and again the best way to get a handle
on this is
not the number of people who are being
picked up through test and trace
because that's just a proportion of the
total it's not the total
so you have to do it through studies
like the ons study
which take random selections or you do
it through
modeling as well and here are some of
the results from
two of the big studies the ons study
which i've talked about
and the react study which is also a big
study done across the
country and then the
data from the modeling groups by them
and what you can see
is that they're estimating uh tens of
thousands of people
getting new infection every day in the
react study between 41 and 53
000 per day the ons 22 700 to 38
200 and the modeling suggesting that it
may now be as high as between 43 000 and
74 000
per day getting the infection and all of
these are a bit lagged they look
backwards
so we would expect it to be towards the
higher end of these at the moment
and you will have seen other data today
suggesting as high as 47 000 per day so
that's the sort of number that's getting
infected every day and then the third is
the r value
next slide please and here what we've
shown is the
r range and you remember it's not a
single value there's a range
from time in may through to now and
the first thing to say is that the red
line points out when the r
is one and at one the epidemic stays at
exactly the same
level below one is shrinking above one
it's growing
and what you can see is that the r
stayed pretty flat
at somewhere between say 0.9 and 0.7
all the way through till the end of july
and then it began to pick up during
august
breached one and is now up at somewhere
between
1.3 and 1.5 that means for every person
with the infection on average they're
infecting 1.3 to 1.5 other people
in other words the epidemic is growing
but what you can
see is that the r hasn't gone back
to where it was and where it would be in
an unmitigated epidemic
of this disease which would be at around
three so it's gone up
the epidemic is growing probably between
four and seven percent per day
but that r hasn't gone right back up and
the reason it hasn't gone right back up
is because of the measures that everyone
is already taking so reducing contacts
reducing contacts in environments which
then foster
spread certain environments are more
likely to do so poorly ventilated and so
on
and making sure that people who've got
the infection isolate
but we're not where we need to be which
is to get the r
to one or below so there's a bit more
work to do to get it down to where it
needs to do to be
next slide please
to move from national to regional and
the cmo
showed similar slides um a while ago but
actually these have now progressed
unfortunately
so if you take the left hand side it
shows the weekly cases per hundred
thousand the population
and on the right hand side it shows how
fast that is growing
the darker the color the darker the
purple on the left the more the cases
the brown color on the right shows
growth and the darker the brown the
faster the growth
and what you can see is that there is a
concentration of
high levels of cases as we know in the
northwest the northeast the midlands and
increasingly in other parts of the
country and that the growth rate
is fastest also in the northwest
some parts of the northeast london and
some other areas as well are increasing
in terms of growth but there's growth
pretty much across the country so the
epidemic is growing everywhere
and as the cmo said it's important to
look also by age how this is growing
because we know
that once it gets into the over 60s and
the over 65s
that's when you start to see a big
increase in hospitalization
and unfortunately the serious
complications including of course
some people who will die from this
disease next slide please
so this is the distribution by age of
over 60.
again purple is a number of cases
darker purple more cases and on the
right hand side is where we're seeing
growth in this age group how quickly
this is growing
the darker the brown the more the growth
and what you can see is again
we're seeing an increase now in the
number of cases in over 60s
particularly in the northwest and the
northeast elsewhere it's growing as well
and you can see the growth rate is
fastest in those areas as well
so this epidemic is growing it's growing
everywhere it's growing faster in some
places and it's spreading
to older age groups next slide please
this is represented in this heat map so
let me
take you through this um so you can
understand what this graph is showing
it's giving you different age groups
well let's look at the south west to
start off with down the bottom left
yellow means rather few cases as the
colors get darker the number of cases
are higher
the age groups are such that the lowest
ages the youngest ages at the bottom and
the highest agents at the top
and what you can see in the south west
is that from
mid-september through to october
there's been a gradual increase in the
number of cases
particularly in the age group of 16 to
29
not much increases yet in the other age
groups
but if you now look at the north east
and north west what you see
is that as the cases increase in the
younger age groups they gradually spread
to the older age groups so that you see
let's take the northeast for example
you see the cases in the 16 to 29 year
olds going
very high and as they go high you then
see the cases increasing
in the 30 to 44 year olds the 45 to 59
and of course the over 60s so we're
seeing a gradual trend
of increased numbers in the young
moving to increase numbers in older age
groups and that is happening now
across the country at different rates in
different places
next slide please that in turn is
leading to
increased hospital admission rates as
the prime ministers said
this is admission rates per 100 000 of
the population from july through to
october
split out by age and you can see that
there is an
increase across most age groups and
of course it's obvious that you're
seeing an increase there in the over 85s
but also in the 75 to 84s
65 to 74s and indeed in younger age
groups
45 to 64. and if you look since
august about 40 of the cases in hospital
are under the age of 60 so it's not just
older people who are going into hospital
younger people are as well next slide
please
the hospitalization is increasing and so
are the intensive care rates
and again this graph shows the increase
in people in intensive care with covered
since the beginning of september you can
see quite a significant increase there
again split out by age and you can see
the relatively big increase
across all age groups really from 45
onwards in terms of the
admission rates into intense care units
next slide please this shows
across the regions where it just mirrors
what
you've seen in terms of the case numbers
northwest north eastern yorkshire
highest numbers and increasing midlands
increasing london beginning to increase
and you can see other areas lower but in
all areas increasing a little bit
so i'm afraid that the news is that that
that although the r
is is such that the epidemic is growing
it's growing not as fast as it was back
in in march or april but it is growing
and it's growing more slowly because the
measures we're taking if we take more
measures to get that below
one and that's often things we need to
do as individuals
then we can get this back under control
but at the moment you can see the
numbers are increasing
leading to hospitalizations leading to
intensive care unit emissions
and that's a current state of affairs of
the epidemic
patrick thank you very very much let's
go to questions first from the public if
we'll go to
christopher from margate what is the
government's guidance to single parents
who have regular contact with their
children
who live in a different county i live in
kent
and my son lives in essex what should i
do regarding contact
if essex or kent were to be a higher
covered alert level
and the other remain at medium well uh
christopher i think the the the guidance
alas is that if
if you should go on the website
obviously and check but
uh when you when places go into a higher
tier
uh from uh from the the basic medium
uh then uh there are restrictions on
household contact uh alas
uh so uh depending on how you define
your
your household uh you may find there are
restrictions but you
you really need to go on to the uh to
the website to
uh to to see where you know what's going
on in ken what's going on in
in essex in order to be absolutely sure
can we go to sarah from uh from plymouth
please
sarah asks uh following the introduction
of three new levels across regions
will you be reintroducing shielding if
so uh where
and how well sarah uh at present we're
not
uh reintroducing uh shielding though
obviously we keep
that under uh under review uh we believe
that the package of measures that we've
got
uh the the local uh restrictions that
we've brought the tiering system
uh will if everybody complies
uh help to protect uh older people help
to protect the
uh the vulnerable uh but obviously we're
going to keep it
under under constant review let's go to
uh questions from the media to to vicky
young please from the bbc
you've just said that time is of the
essence but talks with local leaders
are causing delays don't you know how to
make a
quick decision about whether you impose
those extra restrictions on places
including greater manchester
or give them more money to persuade them
which will it be
and when and to surpass balance
do you think that a short period now of
two to three weeks of tighter national
restrictions some people call it a
circuit breaker
would save more lives than the regional
tier approach
that is carrying on well uh vicki first
of all
uh i think that it's much much better if
we can
uh work with our our friends in uh in
local government in local authorities
across the the country with the
the local tiered approach i don't think
it makes sense as i as i've said to be
locking down uh the whole country when
there's such a
a big difference in uh in the infection
rate
across uh different parts of the of the
uk
and it really doesn't make sense to as i
said to lock down
cornwall or or north norfolk to close
down
uh businesses there which work very hard
to make them make themselves covered
secure
in order to to drive down transmission
uh
in in parts of the northwest and uh
yes of course we're working flat out
with uh
our friends across the uh across all
those all those regions i
pay tribute particularly to liverpool
scenery the city region
uh to steve rotherham i pay tribute to
councillors in lancashire i talked to
them
uh this morning and uh it's good that
london
has also come on board uh as i said
earlier there is an issue outstanding in
in greater manchester uh and i hope that
uh the mayor
of greater manchester will also um you
know come
come with us uh there is a as i said
there is compensation there is
there is support uh that we're making
available
i think you know very good levels of of
support
i hope i hope that uh he understands
that and
the the urgency as you rightly say is
is there and we've got to get this this
done
but it's far better to do it together
because we want the maximum local buy-in
the maximum local
enforcement and the maximum local
compliance and that means
local leadership that is you know all
all the successful
uh uh countries that have been driving
down covid uh epidemics across the world
uh whether in east asia or in europe or
wherever have been taking this
strong locally based approach rather
than imposing
uh nationwide uh lockdowns i think a
local approach
uh is is the right one for us and i hope
that
uh that greater manchester will come on
board but as i said just now
obviously the national government must
reserve the right to to step in uh and
and do what is
what is necessary uh
we recommended um in september about
taking a circuit break and the idea
there was that actually
a two-week interruption would set cases
back probably to the levels they were in
august and then at those levels test and
trace
is more effective to keep control so
that was the reasoning behind that
um where we are now of course the
different uh situation
it's crucial that where the r is above
one and the numbers are high we get the
r below one
for all the reasons that have been
outlined including of course the um
hospitalizations which are increasing so
it's crucial that's done
and there are a number of ways that it
can be done and as the
chief medical officer said um tier 3
baseline
conditions on their own almost certainly
aren't enough to get the r below one but
if you go up to higher levels in in tier
three and start adding in other areas
then you can get
uh they should be enough to get r below
one provided they are fully implemented
and we all
um stick to them uh it's worth
remembering that that when the science
advice is given
one of the things that we're clear about
is that there are other harms that need
to be
uh take into account so there's the
direct harm of covid which we all know
about
there's the indirect harm because beds
become occupied in hospitals and that
prevents other normal care and that
stops treatment of
other diseases cancers and
cardiovascular disease and so on and
that's important to take into account
there's the economy which clearly has
effects on health as well
and and can have very long-lasting
damage and
their effects on society including loss
of education
in terms of disruption of schools and in
terms of
loneliness isolation and uh the mental
and physical effects of lockdown so
those are things that politicians need
to take into account when making the
decision but
but clearly anywhere where the r is
above one
which is most places of the uk actions
need to be taken of some sort and the
higher the levels
the greater the action needs to be in
order to get the r below one
thanks very much uh patrick um
let's go to uh sam coats of sky
prime minister the presentation that you
just showed
showed 40 000 to 50 000 maybe more
new coronavirus cases every day
this looks like we're getting to a point
where significantly tougher restrictions
are needed if not nationally then at
least in
vast parts of the country the lesson of
the first spike was the longer you wait
the worse it gets and the more that
costs the economy so
why not act more draconianly today
and patrick valance politicians all this
week
local and national have been squabbling
rather than acting
are people going to die as a result well
sam i i would just i mean of course
you're right that we do need uh
urgent action in the areas where the
virus is most prevalent as
as as patrick has just said but i i draw
your attention
uh also to uh that that point that
patrick just made about the the r
level uh it it is it is not rising
in the uh the way that it was uh a few
months ago
you're not seeing the the very rapid
doubling
of cases that we are seeing in the
outbreak of the epidemic
there is the chance uh if we implement
uh the measures that i think need to be
taken at a regional at a local
level uh more than a chance that we can
get the the
r down because you need to get another
30 percent of that of that
uh r down and uh you're below one again
and uh that i think would be a
uh that is what we're we're aiming for
and
uh we think that the budget of measures
that we've set out
uh would do it uh as patrick has it if
we all implemented them together uh
if we did it uh together with the local
authorities the regions uh that we've
identified and you're quite right
there's
areas across the country uh that now
need uh to do more
and it will take everybody working
together
to achieve it but i i think as my
judgment is that it's better
to go for that uh route now uh than to
go back to
uh the bad old days of or the you know
the most difficult period
of of uh closing our our schools again
uh alas uh taking uh pupils out of
school
uh forcing people effectively to to stay
at home making it very difficult for
businesses
to continue in a way that causes
long-term economic social
and public health damage so that's the
trade-off it is incredibly difficult
we think that uh we think that the local
approach uh is the best one for now
that's why we're pushing
uh so hard for it that's why i'm
grateful to
to local uh leaders for for what they're
doing
to help but as i say you are you call
for more draconian
measures uh sam uh being no doubt the
government stands ready
uh to apply those measures uh as soon as
we think that they're necessary
well these are horrendously difficult
decisions and there are harms on both
sides has
been pointed out previously and as i
just illustrated
um the from a purely epidemiological
point of view
it's important to go quite fast on this
it's important to make sure that you go
hard enough to get the all below one and
the sooner you do that the more you get
this under control
thanks very much can we go to charlotte
iverson talk radio
thank you prime minister our listeners
and viewers are very concerned about the
future
are you able to categorically rule out
that we won't see
a circuit breaker lockdown or something
that looks like one
in the next month or so and patrick
violence to you as well you've talked
about tier three perhaps not being
enough to get the r below
one would you be able to tell us some
precise examples of further measures
that might be able to help
um well sean as i said earlier on as i
said in my answer just now to
uh to sam i i i rule nothing out uh when
you you mention further measures that
might
be able to help it might be actually
appropriate to bring uh
susan hopkins in uh to talk about some
of the
of the testing possibilities because uh
i also
mentioned those in in uh in my my
remarks but patrick
well i mean is it seasonal so so first
of all i think that the most important
things that we should do are their
personal responsibility we need to take
that first
uh reducing our number of contacts that
we have in all areas even in tier one
and tier two areas are really important
keeping those contacts low working from
home if you can are all really important
measures that we can take
reducing our contacts in indoor spaces
particularly those that are less
ventilated
and then of course there's testing we
are already ramping up and increasing
the testing we're at
300 000 tests a day today aiming to get
to 500
000 by the end of the month and looking
at new technologies where we can find
asymptomatic
infection particularly in the areas that
are most at risk for transmitting to
vulnerable individuals such as care
homes and hospitals
but we're also looking at how we can do
this in universities and schools to keep
education open as much as possible and
as long as possible over the winter
period
while protecting the rest of the
population
and what susan's said is that clearly
isolation is important as the prime
minister said i mean
testing only works if people isolate and
so making sure that we keep as many of
us
out of circulation as possible who are
infected during the time of
infectiousness
is crucial and in terms of the extra
measures they're all laid out what the
extra measures are
and i think that's where local knowledge
and local insight can add and make sure
that enough of those extra measures are
put on top of baseline tier three in
order to get this
working and get the r below one thanks
uh very much thanks charlotte let's go
to matt dayton of the sun
thank you prime minister uh to follow up
charlotte families up and down the
country will be spooked by uh this
latest idea from government scientists
for um
repeated circuit breakers over each
school holiday
are we really looking at our christmas
uh lockdown circuit breaker
uh sir patrick uh is it uh would it
still be effective to do a circuit
breaker over half term
and i've got to ask the prime minister
about brexit i'm afraid
yes you've left your door slightly ajar
today
by telling the eu you'll still be able
to talk to them
um if you see a fundamental change or
approach from them
but you know when will your door slam
shut is it new year's eve are you still
going to pick up your phone then or
would you rather die in a ditch yeah
um well why don't i take those to take
the bits of the meant for
for me patrick uh look matt we want the
the local approach uh the regional
approach uh to work
uh we're giving it our best shot uh
we're working with
uh with local regional mayors uh
city mayors around the country as you
know uh to get this thing done
um and i hope that everybody will take
their responsibilities and
and drive it forward because i don't
want to see this country are constantly
uh locking down in the way that uh in
the way that you describe
uh we did it uh in march uh in april
we did it for a long time and i think
that the regional approach
keeping our kids in school uh keeping
our economy moving
as far as we possibly can and that's
what we're able to do with this approach
i think that is the best way forward uh
because i do think that we can
uh we can drive down that r as i was
saying uh to sam coates
uh earlier on and on uh where we are
with
our friends and and partners in the in
uh
in in europe look um uh
i think there's a uh we've got to the
stage alas where
they don't seem to want to progress a
a free trade deal that was pretty clear
from
uh the conclusions of the summit that
they don't want to go any
uh any further uh unless that
fundamentally
uh changes then uh we're gonna have to
come out on australian terms and but
we'll prosper
mightily nonetheless in terms of the
circuit breakers the circuit breaker is
a way of really pushing
um measures to a hard level to get r
below one quickly and then to release it
and that would break transmission
whenever whenever you do it and it would
therefore slow
and uh and uh buy some time in the
epidemic so it's it's a way of doing it
locally or nationally
but of course it's in a way just an
extreme version of what you're trying to
do to get r below one anyways
there are different ways in which you
can get r below one and
the circuit breaker idea is one way to
do it in a sort of short
um defined period thanks very much let's
go to
uh bill jacobs of the lancashire
telegraph
thank you very much prime minister um
parts of blackburn and pendle have been
under
severe coronavirus restrictions since
august
how long do you think this latest tier 3
is going to take
and how long do you think people can put
up with it
well bill you're asking the most
important uh
question which is really about people's
uh ability to
to to keep going with this and i just
want to say a massive thank you to
to people in in lancashire who you
rightly say have been going through
uh some pretty tough times for a very a
very long time now
i want to say thank you to local leaders
council leaders that i
i talked to this morning uh in
lancashire for the for the steps that
uh they're taking uh to reduce the
spread of vr
in uh reduce the spread of the virus in
uh in lancashire
and you know we can do it we can do it
together
the the the the quantum uh by which the
amount by which we need to reduce
the r uh is is not as big as it was
uh right back in the beginning of the uh
of the spread of this disease
uh if we all work together on the
measures uh we've outlined
uh we can definitely do it and uh and
as i'd like to see lancashire and
everywhere else
coming out of uh tier three as fast as
possible
you've missed one prime minister i have
i'm so sorry you're quite right let's go
to george parker of the financial time
sorry george
that was that was not intentional
forgive me george
thank you prime minister um it does seem
you know in a press conference where
we've been talking about a pandemic
so also we're talking about brexit and
the idea that we might
add more economic uncertainty into an
already very uncertain
time for the country particularly as the
dispute seems to turn on
an issue of fisheries which accounts for
about 0.1 of the british economy
and a dispute about how free you are to
hand out state subsidies to
to industries my specific question is
this you say that
you're prepared hearts high to take the
country out
of the transition period uh without a
trade deal on the lowest common
denominated trade terms that you can
have
how do you explain that to people for
example in the car industry
who will face tariffs of 10 on their
exports or indeed people
in upland rural areas who produce lamb
or beef who
face tariffs of between 40 and 100
percent
are there industries expendable for
brexit well
uh george uh as i've said this this
morning
uh we're very keen to uh get a canada
style
uh outcome as as i explained earlier on
but i think we can prosper mightily
under
uh an australian uh version if we have
to it's it's pretty clear from what
happened at the summit
today that um our friends
uh don't want to negotiate don't want to
offer us the
uh the canadian options so uh we've got
to uh make the necessary preparations
and i've no doubt that all the sectors
uh that you've mentioned all uh this
whole country can get ready
for an australian exit and as i say i'm
absolutely certain that we can do
very well indeed thank you all very very
much
thank you thank you for your time
you